. Cool. Can everybody hear me? Ok,
cool I can hear me, awesome. So, just before
we gene I'm quite a connoisseur of the animated
gif and just in an attempt to be inclusive
- you see that on the slide it means the next
slide contains a gif, if you suffer from vestibular
disorder or something that would make a uncomfortable,
look away, listen to my voice, it's lovely,
interesting and ethnic .
I hope that makes you feel better and doesn't
spoil your enjoyment, the next slide is animated,
this is how I feel after four days!
.
So I like to relax before doing a conference
talk, so I like to make you move, after four
days of sitting down, yeah, probably going
to help. So, hello I'm Lewis Cowper, both
in life and pretty much everywhere on the
internet and I just want to chill out for
a bit. .
So, you have heard a lot of fantastic talks
and I hope you have had a chance to meet fantastic
people and chat to the sponsors and speakers
after the talks, but I would really love you
to stand up for me. Feel free, have a little
dance, little shake off. Everybody take a
deep breath and just hold, it nice and slow.
Now on 3, I want you to blow there {toward
the screen}. 1, 2, 3, go!! .
Wasn't that nice, just relax, it's ok, don't
worry. So, yeah, forklifts and all that. Feel
free to sit down.
Have a glass of water and just enjoy at the
moment.
So, forklift driver to developer in nine months.
I'm@Lewis Cowper, pink sparkly heart JSConf,
please feel free to comment after.
Picture the scene, you wake up, it's still
dark, you fall into clothes, you open the
door to leave and would you look at that,
it snowed. Your job doesn't allow remote working,
your job doesn't require a WiFi connection
and you are not sitting in front of a
computer, you make the best of it, put a fleece
on, gulp down some tea, we're in Britain and
that's how you warm. This is your work, recovered
steel pipe most probably from the oil rig
or field, the ones on the left 5 inch, the
big ones 9 and 5 eighths, in Britain we deal
with Americans, all the sizes make me feel
uncomfortable, your biggest asset is probably
one of these, that bundle right there will
weigh around 3 to 4 tonnes, if you try and
pick them up it doesn't work!  .
So, oh and if you drop that, I've discovered
as well, steel pipe beats ground, so add that
into the rock, paper, scissors thing, steel
win!! And you can break things really easily.
So your job is to move these to your working
area, where you are going to cut the pipe
with something like this. This is, I desperately
tried to find a picture of my actual machine,
but my machine was in a small hut and was
not nearly that clean and yeah, just generally
a bit grimy, we basically built a iron shed
around that with two massive holes in the
side for the roller beds, so it your job is
manual and really repetitive, it's varied,
sometimes something breaks and then you have
to fix it.
. Some correlation. It gives your
brain a lot of free time when you can just
switch off mentally at your job, I spent a
lot of time analysing my work. So if one cut
takes x amount of time, how long would 1384
cuts take, no one bias an even amount, they
by buying distance, it's 1.88m, if I can get
out 7 out of a 12, it's better to drag out
the longer pipe, soon enough my note bats
looked like this, my colleagues, who were
less maths minded than me, thought I was Russell
Crow in a beautiful mind!  .
I love computers, I played with them for number
of years, I like to think it was my analytical
mind that led me to programming or kept it
fresh. I did the basics at school and tried
to go to university for computer science I
was from a very small time, so I spent a lot
of time doing what we have been doing for
the last few days, staying out late and partying,
I signed up for an OU degree, computer science
and design, soon as I got into second year
and introduced to Java, I didn't find it particularly
engaging, I felt like I was learning in a
bubble and without an atmosphere of a classroom,
I didn't seem to be able to focus and understand
why I had to type public stack void main every
time and I still don't. I just wanted to make
a lot of things happen with my computer, not
learn a lot of key words to get around. My
luck started to change, in the next city over,
ten miles away, they were programming meet
ups, people got together in their spare time,
unpaid, talked about programmering and taught
people stuff and asked questions, so combine
people with enthusiasm for teaching and people
who want to learn, the fen diagram is basically
the same, everybody wanted to teach and everybody
wanted to learn, it was fantastic.
It was going to be a crowd and you have to
say the right thing at these meet ups, you
have to know the lingo, so I said public stack
main void before I ordered a drink and everybody
laughed, it kind of worked. I persevered and
learnt the lingo, people there were happy
to chat about the things being discussed or
anything related to DEV environment, when
you feel you have to say the right thing to
fit in and at any time someone will find
out you don't know all the things, you start
sticking to the one thing that gets you through
these meet ups and I liked games, playing
games, I liked the idea of making games. One
of the groups was putting on a Gamejam in
a month or so and I thought oh wow, I can
do some actually programming here, I looked
at code on slides before at meet ups it was
easy, definitely wrong, what they don't show
in the code slides is the other 100 that make
those work, I went to Google game tutorials
to learning programming and discovered Python,
one caught my eye, rogue like library, the
5 hour tutorial took 17, I had functioning
game, it was really cool, it was the first
time I made something from scratch.
When I went to the Gamejam, somebody asked
if anybody wanted to do Python, I was like,
yes, this is fantastic, I don't need to go
a rogue like on my own, I latched on to the
people doing Python and didn't let go.
Then there was a team, a team of people who
knew that I had literally never done anything
until the weekend before and were able to
skeleton out the game and let me play with
random variables and see, you know, how to
implement proper looking gravity and stuff
like that. Like I even, I was quite proud,
I implemented a Para. lacks scrolling library
for a platformer when my team mates set we
don't have time for that, 20 minutes later
it was done, I was King of the world.
It was there that I met somebody who did Java
as work, I said hey I'm learning Java, I should
ask them what it's like to be a junior developer,
he came in at that same kind of place and
gone through they're process, on job adverts,
looking for a junior developer, three years
experience programming in eight different
languages is like, what!! Like, seriously!?
Catch 22, junior developer, three years' experience,
either they not junior or they are not training
the people in three years the right thing
and you should just not be doing that. So
the company you work for hired developer via
QA, you would spend a couple of years in the
QA department, moving from manually to automated
testing, then in DEV team testing, essentially
when you get familiar enough with integration
tests, you write unit tests and then code
to go with them, it seemed like a better job
than forklift driving, air conditioned office,
free water, what could go wrong!
So I sent a CV away, heard nothing. Got in
touch with my friend who said they couldn't
find my CV, I thought ok I'll try again, tried
again, I took a note that an error assisted,
at the same time as there was an error processing
your application, congratulations CV submitted
successfully, I thought that might be weird.
My friend got in touch after a few weeks and
said they still didn’t have any record of
it, I sent an email with screen shots to reproduce
the bug that I'd found, as it turns out that
was a pretty good higher for QA, it did that
for a while but soon got very, very bored
to make sure the flow works on a different
build, but I lived in the town where all the
meet ups were, so I was able to leave work
and go to the meet up without rushing, Python,
bit of Ruby, video games, but I really, really
liked one of them, the JavaScript group, I
loved how the language looked .
Great. There is an excuse. I loved how the
language looked and I saw Ashley's talk describing
iteration through an array. If you look at
Ruby when you already know what iteration
is, it looks really nice, when you look at
JavaScript it actually explains what it's
doing, it's great. There's still like semicolon
and I would reference a function it wouldn't
call I wouldn't know why because it was there
was no brackets on the end. So yeah.
At the time I got into JavaScript round February
last year having been programming for 2 or
3 months at various meet ups every month or
so I would do anew thing. So this was well
into node being a thing, IE 11 had been out
for a few months I’m like a clean slate
for somebody presenting JavaScript as if for
the first time. They have played JavaScript
image in the past they tell you what do you
like in programming you say JavaScript they
go oh I am sorry. Come on you're programming
you can open the DevTools and do this. JavaScript
was power, power over something that I just
loved which was the web, you could take any
website and ruin it in the DevTools, break
everything because you completely didn't understand
what was happening but you knew 4 functions
if you applied them in the right way you could
break everything, it was fantastic.
It felt like you could just type vaguely what
you wanted to happen and it worked. I mean
I was doing simple stuff but it was amazing
how quickly you can go from hey there's this
thing from JavaScript to enough power, enough
knowledge to be dangerous. I really liked
the Jennifer quote from the intro on Friday
which is JavaScript is pseudocode with semi-colones
on the end. I get that. It was just under
9 months or about 8 months that after I started
doing manual testing that we had. I had gone
to ScotlandJS seen some fantastic, started
giving talks at user groups about things I
didn't know anything about, but an opening
in the UX team who were working on their first
AngularJS application having being doing Java
rendered pages for end tyre company's laugh,
I think I said JavaScript often enough in
the interview they were like yeah we'll take
you on. I got the job.
So there's a team of hackers we're all doing
JavaScript it's all so fun. I get the title
of the talk I may have mislead you I didn't
want to come here just to tell you my story,
because now I am a developer that's where
the story ends but I want to tell you about
some of things that helped me along some,
I learned myself some that others taught and
definitely some that I wish somebody had said
sooner. This talk is for you if you no anybody
starting on the path to becoming a developer
whether that's you useful, yourself, a colleague,
somebody who's interested they don't know
how to deal with that. Or even if you are
watching this thing that's me I want to move
into development I came here to learn and
be interested.
Firstly, I would just say that this is not
the right way to teach people modern web development.
I realise you can't see, oh no it's actually
contrast quite well you cannot read it, it’s
entirely deliberately it's the stack from
ThoughtWorks training course the JavaScript
toolkit which is great for experienced developers
who want to know what tools they have available
across everything, but when you're new, you
feel like all the things? I have to
learn all of that before I can write a website?
This is useless. I think it's important we
should make learning materials at whatever
level as accessible as you possibly can so
we can take people from this to this and be
excited about learning the things they need
to learn. Let's go through some of things
you could and should know about what I value
as a new developer.
First one, honesty. It always nice. Because
when you start out you break something you
hit an error, you feel like you're the only
one that's having this problem and having
it because you're stupid and you don't know
anything. You can't figure out the right key
word to search for, you can't ask somebody
because that would be terrible they will fire
you because oh my God you have caused an error
it's broken something on your computer. That's
terrible. You feel like failures, what they
don't realise it's that everybody programming
all the time breaks everything we just get
better at fixing it. Right?
So when you have got a junior developer that's
having a tough time with some new syntax or
trying to go into ES6 or something, support
them but try and let them come across the
answer themselves. If you write the code for
them, you're just writing abracadabra, we
have an app. It doesn't work no-one learns
anything, people just as lost as me with things
that I had come across helped a lot. It felt
less like I was coding in a bubble, the thing
I did know started becoming relevant.
So if open source this next GIF perfectly
encapsulate what I felt I will just look at
that repository that looks like an interesting
project. It turns out that there's a lot of
open source software at there, not all of
them are great learning experience but there's
a lot to learn from the community surrounding
some of them are amazing I want to take a
moment to highlight Hoodie that was my introduction
last February my first commit an open source
project if you do know anybody who's does
want to get involved in the community tar
some other awesome initiatives out there to
help newcomers the Rails Girls project, very
recently they finished their Summer of Code
where they crowdfunded a large basically trying
to pay people who wanted to get into development
and take them under the wing of an open source
project, who was happy to mentor them and
answer any questions. It's fantastic. Their
statistics are incredible, I urge anybody
who wants to help to look to them as a real
shining example of how to run an initiative
like that but back to my thoughts on things
and stuff.
Source control, I am not going to go too deep
on what source control is if you're not using
it my now you should be you know that's fine,
we're here all good, but as far as a new developer,
they may have never used it. I remember my
friend telling me during a team project at
his masters university, that will remain nameless
he asked his professor, what happens if 2
people edit the same file, how do we fix that,
is there a nice way of doing it, and he was
told that the project manager should make
sure that doesn't happen.  which
works, bit cheap though because you have the
opportunity to take someone through source
control for the first time, we have been using
it for decades now, as long is I have been
alive. New people
don't necessarily have the mental models of
what happens when you do a Git ad they get
push, they may any some help with what might
seem like simple or chore Git tasks. I discovered
when you are doing an open source project
you branch you do the Github thing you do
branch commit, then open a pull request but
because you can do a tremendous amount through
the Github UI you never get exposed to the
commands going on. I have been quite taken
for using a graphical client for when multiple
people are working on it, if you know someone
who's struggling with Git, explaining the
principles rather than saying these are the
commands you need to run is probably well
worth your time.
This is one of the things that people are
all levels tell everyone, whether it's a firm
or object orientated programmer trying to
get some programming or front end it always
helps to see alternative ways of doing this.
Innumerable talks suggesting you write a list
to get under the skin of a functional programming
works. The limit on what you can learn by
trying new things out doesn't exist, but I
think it's important to remember when you
are new don't dive too deep. You will wind
up with a load of breadth of knowledge in
every which way of doing a single thing but
because you have never taken the step forward
and tried to do more you end up having a coloured
few on what some languages can and can't do.
Keep in mind the next 2 points. They say even
in my very young career I have heard a lot
premature optimisation is the root of all
evil. I suggest that goes triply so for you
software development education. Don't worry
about how quickly you are learning slow down
the relax about, it I know coming to conferences
trying to keep up with all the new technologies
and webapps out there means you feel like
you have got to go fast, but honestly learn
apt your own pace it's super easy to get burned
out on learning and not really enjoy what
you are doing because you are continuously
thinking about all the things you don't know.
I say find your niche, because frankly the
stack doesn't matter here we're at JSConf
we properly have JavaScript in our stack at
some point that not necessarily the best fit
for everybody. So what you want to find out
it's at what level you want to work. With
you trying everything you might stumble across
something that really clicks for you. For
me it was the web for you it might be systems
programming you might really, really love
concurrent thread port server, I don't know
the words I know they exist I just shove them
into a sentence, sometimes people say oh yeah
I get what you mean. I have also heard that
in systems programming everything has to be
web scale. Is that a thing? I don't know,
but yeah. Find your niche and explore more
the worse thing that will happen is that you
learn more about something and learn that
you don't really care for it that much and
that's fine.
That's minimum viable product idea that goes
round take the minimum shippable thing because
shipping culture it has his own problems but
that's for another talk. We should really
get into habit of teaching new developers
they should get it working force, then focus
on making it better because if they apply
the same principles and it doesn't work, they
have no idea why. Just for those of you in
the back that is a pile of sand being held
down by a 3 inch or 4 inch wide strap which
looks like it might work, probably
won't. I have lost count of how many times
I have made a start trying to solve something,
then second guess myself because some inconsequential
implementation detail was not perfect them
then I was completely sidetracked from my
train of thought. If I could get offer this
my Github profile would get a lot busier,
but the number one thing that led me here
to talk you all whether that's people in your
local dev community, helpful people who answer
questions on Twitter, people in open source
communities people in slack RIRC, everyone
and people were the number one thing that
inspired me to join this web community. We
need to start considering interpersonal skills
as a major part of levelling up as a junior
dev.
We need to remain accountable for our action's
programming is not the preserve of the super
educated anymore you have access to computers
that fill entire rooms and can take a punch
card and spit out some binary, but we have
moved past that. Anybody with a computer of
any kind, anybody who picks up a Firefox OS
phone or 30 bucks or whatever can try out
web programming they can make an app in I
think the current record upstairs was something
like of seconds. They have an app it's there,
they can use it, they can interact with it
they can learn from it immediately, that's
fantastic, but the problem with people is
that they are haters out there. If you go
down stack overflow and say hey I am having
a bit of trouble adding these 2 number again
what should I do the first answer is, use
a jQuery plug-in, no please don't do that.
You need to be encouraging, giving them things
to do that are would help them understand
because otherwise, certain websites look like
this. You ask a question, and immediately
everybody leaps down your throat oh my God
you are using angular 1.2 you terrible human
being. I always like to think it's GIFs because
I like animation, but do you know who deserves
to learn from you and who you can learn from?
Literally everyone. Thanks Gary.
So, in short, one year and 26 days ago today,
I began my new life as a software developer,
about 7 weeks ago I moved to Berlin and changed
job and I am now a junior front-end dev, I
am very happy. Because I am standing up here
hopefully I can help at least one more person
gain the confidence to get involved too. So
thank you very much I have been Louis Cowper.
Actually, is that timer right? If I have got
5 minutes, I have got 3 minutes here. Just
a quick thing I have got a few minutes, I
want to just take a moment to talk about something
that I have been working really hard on, oh
that's not mirroring. That will work. Yeah
so let's look at Hoodie, and Hoodie CSSI have
been working on a tool that takes a Markdown
trial and pretty prints it with chalk it's
not really fully done and code blocks don't
look too good. What I have in package JSON
is MPM run help I would thoroughly urge anybody
using MPM as a build tool to try that when
you run PMP run as normal you just get a list
of the script that can be really be helpful
if you already know what all the dependencies
do but I just want to promote, oh I am off
the bottom, sorry.
When you run MPM as normal you just get a
list of the scripts, it can be really helpful
if you already know what all the dependencies
do, but I just want to promote I'm off the
bottom, ok, sorry, MPM run, help, input file
which I hold ooh... what happened there? That
was fantastic! Still working on it, great,
hold on. Come on, stop, there we go, no! No!
Don't ask me! ! Basically we have the marked
down file we can keep in sync, it looks great
in Github, take the input of run and add comments,
tell people why you are doing what you are
doing, it hopefully will take off and everybody
will really like it, it will help you go from
hey, what does this dependency too, great
to NPM start, awesome!  thanks.